and progressive policies getting called
out for the crime wave ripping across
the country democrat new york city mayor
eric adams putting the pressure on woke
laws that put dangerous criminals back
onto the street
major mistakes made throughout the years
that destroyed the trust that the police
commissioner is talking about we have to
rebuild that trust but we can't rebuild
that trust by allowing those who are
dangerous and that have they have a
repeated history of violence to continue
to be on our streets
greg we're heading into the summer we
usually see these upticks and crimes in
summer as well
and the mayor says that
on on the sunday show and leading into
the summer like he has a choice to make
so you know side with the victims and
the people of the city that want more
security or with these woke democrats
like bragg his prosecutor we went from
christ has risen to crime has risen
how do you like that you work on that
yes for took me two hours
it's not about it's it's not about crime
it's about the recidivism i mean the
thing is uh the crime would go down if
you stopped letting the people out that
were committing the crimes i think
that's where we we've we've run into
this problem when we go like well when
we look at every suspect in these crimes
and they have just like a paper trail
and you start to think well in all of
these arenas of society whether it is
crime or education
the border there's a rejection of
systems and structure and process we
used to be okay with that but then we
started talking about the systemic
problems and we started taking apart
these processes and that's really bad
for a society that naturally decays
we're already in tropic we already get
older things fall apart that is why you
have prisons and you have laws you have
borders and you have standards
and now we're basically saying that the
same sensible rules and laws that we
have for everybody are now not for
everybody because we have the systemic
bigotry the systemic racism so we've
reduced in some ways eliminated
disincentives for crime
and then crime goes up so you have
somebody who's now a shooting suspect
who's in house arrest you've really
you've eliminated one disincentive which
is prison
it might be not such a bad thing risk to
commit crime if the worst thing you're
gonna get is sit at home with your ankle
bracelet so that's the issue the issue
here is that we're dismantling the
things that society desperately needs to
hold us together judge what do you think
about the decision to grant the bail at
25 000 in the ankle monitor option it's
absurd and it's a reflection of where we
are in our society you know greg is
talking about the uh you know the
elimination of the disincentives what
we're seeing now during the holidays you
see crime surge among family members and
in the summer you see crime on the
streets among gang members but today
based upon what the left has done in
this so-called social justice agenda is
they're making crimes at malls like the
one in south carolina a club shooting in
south carolina and an airbnb in
pennsylvania we're talking about 10
people shot 11 people shot this kid
getting out a house monitor with an
ankle brace you should be ashamed of
yourself whoever that judge is should be
ashamed of herself or himself what we've
got is progressive policies that are
destroying this country and the truth is
that it is the deliberate release of
these individuals who go out and commit
crime because they have been emboldened
by the lack of consequence
that we have created with this social
justice agenda there is now a more more
of an interest in the criminal than the
victim and i i feel like a broken record
i keep saying that but it's about the
violent among us in trying to make them
better when the truth is that what
they're doing is making society worse
and you know
this is something that is only going to
get worse as people come in through the
border you know they talk about 23 and
we'll talk about this later on terrorist
lists but but there's so many who don't
get caught and you know they see what's
going on they see americans aren't being
held accountable why should they hell
i'm here for the american dream and i
don't mean to put them all down a lot of
them are working hard but what we've got
is a message that we have sent to 300
and whatever million people it's okay if
you see your neighbor's house and you
want something in it you want the car if
you kill someone it's an accident we'll
let you get away with it it's terrible
the la county sheriff rip that
prosecutor gascon i think we have this
sound if we could play that please
i've had one conversation with him that
was his first week in office where we
had an issue of mutual concern on a cape
one particular case but his predecessor
we met every three months i met her in
her office she met me in my office we
shared concerns exactly what you're
saying we did well this gentleman unless
you come from the public defenders
office uh
you were a black lives matter activist
those are about the only people he's
speaking to everyone else just doesn't
exist in this world
jessica i get your thoughts on that and
just the crime in general that is
increasing all across america
it's objectively terrible and these
showdowns that are going to go on
between sheriffs and da's or the mayors
and da's that's going to be happening in
liberal cities all over the country
certainly as we head into an another
speed of elections where people make big
decisions
and i think what's going on at least in
liberal communities is people feel
betrayed by
these people that we elected to be
ambassadors for our values so i'm
someone who believes in second chances
that i would rather someone who can get
it right not go and even spend one night
in prison if they can get back on the
street and they cannot do it again
but when people are continually letting
you down in this way and it doesn't seem
like the officials that you put in
charge of the problem who you thought
had the same values as you get it then i
think people are going to either stop
showing up for elections i don't think
they're necessarily going to turn on who
they vote for it would take a lot to
make the upper west side vote for a
republican
but
it does leave an opportunity at least to
be having these very tough conversations
that democrats in a lot of cases don't
have a good answer for and it'll be
interesting to see if republicans can
come up with solutions themselves that
can appeal to people because at this
moment in liberal cities you're not
turning la red
right but what are you going to do about
it if you are someone who has a
different point of view or who thinks
that these policies are really putting
people in danger and i haven't seen that
coming from the other side but it's
there except that every time a
republican tries to to position
themselves as pro-crime you're pro you
paint them as racist or intolerant and
so there is there's a one-party system
in new york no no republican bothers to
vote anymore because there's no way and
this is happening in every city there's
no other opposition because the
opposition is essentially smeared at
every opposition every democrat is
smeared as a
communist social
oh i forgot no i mean the name calling
obviously when you're talking about real
issues it becomes a tremendous problem
but i think that when you see the
parents of children who've been killed
who reach out to people like george
gascon and and and boudin in san
francisco who can't get an answer people
like gascon who are releasing convicted
murderers without telling the victims
that they're coming out those are the
people who are calling out the democrats
but like lucy macbeth or these people
who've lost their kids to gun violence
they don't feel like they're being
listened to by the republican party at
all
but did the criminal go to jail did the
criminal go to jail yes if you're saying
that the gun didn't go to jail then she
feels she wasn't listened to okay but
the criminal went to jail and that's the
job but judge we're in the same side of
this issue i look at i look at whether
it's guests going da's and judges and
sheriffs they're all elected by people
this is a democracy and so we have
people in la and new york that are
electing woke liberal officials that
implement these policies and then we're
outraged by the crime that happens with
the policy but really the people have
asked for the policy because they voted
for these folks to take the position of
power and so if you want to change the
narrative you have to change elected
officials and whether it's republicans
or democrats um i don't care who i just
want someone to be pro-law enforcement
one last point when you look at these
policies that have that have changed
over the course of the last two or three
years and there's this explosion in
crime this wouldn't have happened 30
years ago because we had ethics and
morals and values and we had families
but something's happened to your point
greg in culture where there's been a
degradation that when you have lax
policies where you can commit a crime
and just get the ankle bracelet people
are committing them where 30 years ago
they never would have what do you pick
up the gun
i said 30 years well that was nothing
i agree with you on that crime was
pretty bad right now not like this
that's how we got the crime
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else